okay so
we have been in and today we are
finishing the topic of cryptography okay
and you understand that the reason why
we in a maths subject right and in fact
if you go to university and you have the
um privileged satch horror of um
studying maths at university you'll find
that um cryptography and codes and
ciphers
comes under the school of mathematics
and statistics which is where i studied
it which is where 90 of what i'm
teaching you today is about okay
so
it's mathematical because we take this
idea of a text right this is just this
is just revision and we turn it into a
cipher text
by means of well how do we do it what's
this thing in between here what do we
transform yeah
okay so we have
this process of encryption
but it's not just encryption there are
lots of different ways to encrypt
information and they all involve so far
mathematical algorithms right
some of them are very simple like the
very first one you learned which was the
caesar cipher very good okay they get
more sophisticated they uh they can
involve some really crazy level mats
when we had a look at the rsa
cryptosystem okay
um
but there's a particular class of
numbers that are very important to this
whole process right and we spent last
week looking at those kinds of numbers
how you know what they are and how you
test for them what are the most
important numbers to encryption prime
numbers very good okay so these are
going to use prime numbers
a whole lot okay prime number is very
very important and you saw because of
how we dug into the mathematical
processes why prime numbers are
important okay
particularly to like the the lock and
key system where you hand out locks
which are very you can you can lock
messages up but you can't open the mac
up uh prime numbers are kind of the key
to making that work literally the key
okay
but but there's a second kind of number
that's almost as important as prime
numbers to this whole encryption process
and that's random numbers okay now just
have a think about this for a second
why might you think and i want you to
shout and answer i want you to think
about this just here why don't you think
random numbers are actually important
to encryption
why might random numbers be useful and
actually really they are vital to the
whole encryption process
what do you recommend it makes it harder
for the
firm to decrypt it
okay so let's think about this this is
correct but i want you to have a think
about why can we all try and answer this
question of why is this true your answer
was random numbers make it harder
to decrypt the message
right and naturally um
you want decryption to actually be hard
because if it were easy then people
could find out whatever your secrets
were okay so follow-up question then
this is true but why is it true why
would random numbers make it harder to
decrypt what are your kinetic because
you don't know what to expect
okay so let's get to that idea okay that
phrase you just said you should all
write down because very important to
this whole process that you don't know
what to expect
don't know what to expect
in other words to put it
in a single
word right
random numbers are unpredictable right
that's why you don't know what to expect
and unpredictability is really important
to encryption because if if it's
predictable if i know exactly what
you're going to do next
then i can decide for your message right
and this this idea here is the whole
principle on which after the caesar
cipher we learn a second method of
encryption do you remember what it was
it was what the germans used kind of
right
there was a there was a piece of paper
that was involved one-time pads right so
one-time pads are kind of the um
the embodiment of unpredictability there
is no way you can work out what's going
to come next okay which is why it's it's
unbreakable right
so um random numbers right what makes a
series of numbers random is two things
the first is that they're unpredictable
you don't know what to expect okay so
this is kind of like property number one
okay the second property
is what we call uniform distribution
okay which means that
all of the numbers in this range right
they're all equally likely to occur okay
if they're not only equally likely to
occur for instance if it's far more
likely to get you know if you had a die
okay and you were rolling it and like
half of the time you rolled sixes six
six and you know every second turn you
got a six okay there's not a uniform
distribution that's not random anymore
you would not call that a fair dime or
you'd call it loaded or unfair right so
that's the longer random something is
affecting you
so these are the two qualities that
we're after right
now there are two ways to achieve this
okay and we're going to draw a table to
compare these two things
they're called true random number
drainages and
pseudo random number generators okay so
um true
for pseudo
i think that's how you spell it
random number
generators okay so i want us to drop a
little table to compare these two things
okay so the first thing we're going to
think about when we're comparing true
random numbers and pseudo-random genders
whatever they are okay is how do these
things work how do they work okay so
true in a number generator i gave you an
example of one just a second ago a die
right a die
or like a coin toss those kinds of
things they're actually random okay so
the key here though is that i have to
use something i have to use an object of
some kind okay so in other words there's
a physical element to it
okay i need some kind of object now
we're not just limited to coin tosses or
to rolls of the dice you can also you
can take any kind of physical phenomena
like listening to sounds right
take the sound that gets recorded off of
this and that's uh you can represent
that digitally and that will give you
some numerical values but it is it comes
from a physical thing right and then
that'll give you some sense of
randomness
um
pseudorandom generators random number
generators on the other hand are trying
to think about all of these tools that
we know right
which is that
this is the domain of numbers right so
surely there's some kind of mathematical
way
that we can use like
some kind of algorithm or function and
pump out random numbers in a similar way
i suppose to how we pumped out prime
numbers with our prime number generators
from last week
now you probably can see as well if you
can take some numbers right and crunch
through them and spit out random numbers
clearly you can do the same thing with
these numbers if these are your starting
points right so just as an example right
you could take all of your the numbers
that you get from rolling the dice and
then you could you know multiply them by
some number uh or you can multiply them
by the previous number that you just
wrote or you could add something or
whatever you could do more mathematical
transformations after you roll the dice
okay because suppose you want more
random numbers than just one to six okay
so you can do these both together but
the idea here is that i just want to
start with just numbers
no no dice involved
so now let's think about the properties
that these two things have okay
will such a
method of generating random numbers will
it be
a uniform distribution okay will there
be sort of like a nice even spread all
the numbers are equally probable okay
well if you're rolling dice are all the
numbers equally
it's a yes right assuming it's a fair
die okay
if you use a mathematical number
generator
can you get a uniform distribution of
numbers hmm now the short answer is it
depends it depends if you use very
simple maths it's quite hard but if you
use more advanced maths it's actually
doable you can get a pretty even spread
and i will show you an example of this
in a second okay
now
what was the other thing this you don't
know what to expect that is
unpredictable okay so another way of
saying this um instead of
unpredictability which is kind of an
awkward word okay we say independence or
statistical independence right
uh that
one number doesn't depend on the
previous numbers right and the
subsequent numbers don't depend on what
you get now okay
now let's have a think about this you've
got your
say your flip of the coin okay so when
you are flipping a coin
does one flip of the coin
okay let's give this a go
someone call it
it's heads
well done i'm just curious by the way
how many people set heads
heads down who said tails
interested you're not 50 anyhow okay
fine now i'm gonna i'm gonna flip the
coin again okay someone call it
heads again
now did the second toss and talk coin
have anything to do
with the first toss
it's a no they were completely
independent
so hopefully i've answered the question
here of is a true render node generator
which involves some kind of physical
element to it is it independent the
answer is yes it is
aha
but now when you come to this idea
of trying to get numbers from one to the
next and using some kind of mathematical
process an algorithm to get your
generation of random numbers right
necessarily
all the numbers are going to be
connected in some way because you're
getting them through some kind of
mathematical function right and
mathematics by definition is full of
patterns and order right
so therefore you're kind of busted on
this one right and i'll i'll show you an
example of this in a second even quite
sophisticated ways there's going to be
two problems okay firstly
thinking back to um
your knowledge of trigonometry okay if
you've had a look at graphs of
trigonometric functions right which is
an example of an algorithm you can use
to process numbers we call those graphs
periodic what does periodic mean when
it's talking about graphs
fantastic so uh you know you can see
what it looks like here's a sine graph
and it looks the same forever okay in
fact you only need to take this little
section here and you can get the rest of
it that that sort of period is repeated
right so it has a frequency
so all mathematical functions are going
to do something like this right
another way of saying this is that these
are these functions are all
deterministic that's a big word for you
it's also a word for philosophy it means
if you know all the information in the
situation okay you can exactly
predict what will happen next if you
know all the mathematical machinery that
pumped out those numbers okay it's
deterministic you know exactly what's
going to happen
so so far it looks like it's not a very
even race does it right it looks like
clearly these are a better way to go
than these like this is good but
this is bad and that's a significant
band right
and this might be a bit way out but you
know with the rolling the dice or
flipping the coin
there is still a mathematical way to
calculate whether it's going to be heads
or tails like what complex like how hard
you throw it okay like how many times
it's going to spin yeah right so so then
the question becomes okay because you
know when you think about this i'm very
glad you raised that right um i'm going
to flip this a few times and you can see
right that actually you know trying to
answer this question if you knew enough
i'm not i'm not coordinating enough to
do this talk and do this at the same
time if you knew enough then surely you
actually could work out what is going to
be it'll be incredibly complicated but
you kind of could right
so yeah that's that's the whole question
of is there something which is really
truly random as as you'll see um there's
kind of just
random enough
we'll be random for a second
now
there is a whole reason why pseudo
random number generators you can see why
it's pseudo by the way sooner means like
kinda but not really
pretty close but it's kind of like i
can't believe it's not butter but it's
actually not butter okay
so so what's the saving grace
of the pseudorandom generator why do we
use it and the answer is
there's another
attribute
that you need to know about
and that is
efficiency
okay
so you were watching me right like how
many times how quickly i wasn't even a
flip how quickly can you flip a coin
right like even if you have like a whole
bunch of people flipping coins or
rolling dice or whatever okay whatever
process you use because it has a
physical element to it which is why it's
so advantageous right
it's very inefficient it takes a lot of
time it's very time consuming okay so
this is a bust here whereas if all you
have to do is play with numbers
you give it a process you program that
and you can get a computer to do this
and it's super efficient you can pump
out millions of random numbers here even
if they're not quite random because of
these things but you can pop out
millions in the time it takes to do a
few of these okay literally